et vous
ça va pas ça va pas c'est nul je trouve
qu'il y a une belle ambiance
[Musique]
nul nul l'activité creuser cette sorte
et Messieurs le train TER en provenance
de Pontault-Combault et à destination de
Libourne Saint-Seurin vers d'autres
parties prenez garde à la fermeture des
portes
[Musique]
et nous
comment il fait le canard
oui comment il fait le cheval
comment il fait le chien
le chien
ça fait 10 minutes 10 minutes je cherche
le début du scotch c'est le début là le
truc qui devient invisible c'est passé
invisible et en plus il y a des gens ils
ont une capacité à voir le début du
scotch tu leur file qu'on sait comme ça
là
comment tu as fait pour voir